The Women's March. I'm 77
and I'm gonna keep going and won't go back,
as I was not always told that I had as much power as I now know I do.
We're voting on Tuesday, and we just wanna do as much as we can
to make sure that our voices are heard.
Democracy. We need everyone to vote,
everyone to do their. Do their job.
I wanna be the owner of my body
and wanna be able to do what I need to do when it's my choice.
Are you voted? I already have.
Wow. Let's see it.
Do it. You're not too young,
you're not too old. And make the right choice.
And so and so,
when it comes to voting, we need all hands on deck.
Now get out there and vote.
Don't think that this election doesn't have consequences.
Yes, it does,
because it does. It does. Whatever.
If you want your voice to be heard,
you have to make it heard by voting.
Yeah! Get out there, man.
Get out there! Don't be afraid.
Use your voice. You are the future. Please vote.